jeder von euch hat diesen Zug sicherlich
irgendwo schon mal gesehen die Rede ist
vom japanischen schinkansen er ist einer
der schnellsten Hochgeschwindigkeitszüge
der Welt und ermöglicht es blitzschnell
in fast alle Teile des Landes zu kommen
Zugfahren in Japan ist unfassbar gut
organisiert und das Streckennetz gilt
als sicherstes der Welt hier kommt man
als Europäer wirklich ins staun ich
teste heute die First Class im
schinkansen von der Mega City Tokyo nach
Kyoto viel Spaß bei einem neuen zugtest
und damit J Leute was geht und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen Video ich
hoffe natürlich euch geht es allen gut
ich befinde mich gerade in Japan tok und
hinter mir seht ihr die main station von
Tokyo und von hier aus fahren alle
möglichen schinkansenzüge quer durch
Japan na ja seitdem ich hin und wieder
mal Züge teste steht der schinkansen
auch ganz ganz oben auf meiner Liste ich
würde mal sagen es ist mit einer der
berühmtesten Züge der Welt und ich habe
auch schon ganz oft Kommentare von Euch
gelesen Alex wenn du in Japan bist Check
auf jeden Fall den schinkansen ab und
das machen wir heute ich muss sagen der
Bahnhof sieht eigentlich ganz
interessant aus man wird jetzt nicht
denken dass dahinter Züge fahren aber
das ist riesig unser Plan ist es heute
hier in tok zu starten und ca 2 Stunden
und bisschen nach Kyoto zu fahren das
ist wohl auch eine der berühmtesten und
beliebtesten Strecken hier und wir
fahren natürlich erste Klasse wir haben
gestern im Hotel mal gefragt wie das ist
kann man vorher reservieren und die
meinten wir sollen einfach hier zum
Bahnhof Rennen und ein Ticket buchen
deswegen würde ich sagen wir gehen jetzt
mal rein die Dinger fahren alle 15
Minuten und das wohl mit nah zu
hundertprozentiger pünkttigkeit deswegen
das klingt doch schon mal gut oder los
geht's was ich interessant finde die
Leute machen hier sogar Fotos vor dem
Bahnhof hast du schon mal ein Foto vor
Köln Hauptbahnhof gemacht oder Dortmund
Hauptbahnhof das soll ein ganz ganz
toller Bahnhof wir doch da müssen wir
noch ein Foto machen so auf jeden Fall
könnten wir da vorne rein ich glaube man
kann h überall rein wir gehen einfach
mal da rein ich habe keinen Plan wo hier
das Ticket Office ist aber wir werden es
schon finden okay was haben wir hier
marunucci North entrance okay und ich
glaube das oben links steht für den
schinkansen Travel Service Reisebüro
okay da wär auchch Automaten aber besser
hier hoffentlich können die Englisch
weil ich glaube nur so 10% der Japaner
sprechen Englisch das ist immer ein
bisschen schwierig hier Kyoto
schinkandel yes okay thank
you
don't have just only
forck on the
dep9
[Musik]
das doch einfach ne das super okay Leute
Tickets gekauft heute hin und zurück
bezahlt habe ich umrechnen sch mal
66€ 410 € hin und zurück für zwei
Personen ja ist schon teuer ne aber okay
mal los hier ist es doch
12:39 uh das ist unser Vorgehen ke
machen okay so wir fahren auf jeden Fall
von gleich 16 los und was auch ganz
interessant ist an Bord gibt es auf
jeden Fall kein boardbistro aber es gibt
wohl vorher noch so Automaten wo man
sich Essen holen sollte oder das ist
wohl hier so ein Ding bin mal gespannt
wie das gleich aussieht aber das Essen
an Bord was man dann mitnehmen kann ist
auf jeden Fall ganz interessant okay
schinkansen genau ich habe keinen Plan
ob wir so einen haben oder so ein es
gibt ganz viele verschiedene Typen aber
das werden wir wohl noch herausfinden
die meisten schinkansenzüge sind auf
jeden Fall weiß wir sind mit dem nosomi
schinkansen Gefahren dieser fährt bis zu
300 km/h es gibt allerdings auch einige
grüne und einige rote schinkansen diese
fahren allerdings meistens in den Norden
des Landes schaffen aber beide bis zu
320 kmh und sind damit die schnellsten
Züge auch interessant es gibt einen
einzigen gelben schinkhansen von den
Japanern wird der DR yellow genannt
dieser fährt seit 1974 durch Japan
kontrolliert aber ausschließlich die
Strecke die Route ist dabei streng
geheim und das gilt als Glückstag wenn
man diesen gelben schinkansen sieht ich
habe ihn leider nicht gesehen so wir
müssen glaube ich hier hoch und fahren
mit dem Tokaido schinkansen also dieser
blaue oder das Logo ist zumindest blau
wo ist denn hier gleich 16 da hinten ne
da okay noch mal Ticket zeigen
zack danke gleich 16 jetzt haben wir es
gefunden ist auf jeden Fall ordentlich
was los hier aber das ist hier überall
so sorry sorry ja tut mir leid hat sie
mich
beleidigt also hier ist alles so
geordnet dam Herren
dieterf Minuten der neue lockfer steh ah
okay hier haben wir schon die Züge ein Z
ja da also das ist ja das oh sorry sorry
das ist ja das krasseste die Spitze ne
und hier hat man jetzt überall noch so
Automaten und eigentlich sollte man hier
dann ah hier gibt's dieses Essen D ich
meinte also erstmal ist ganz interessant
hier stehen überall zugmitarbeiter die
gleich an jedem Alter wie viele ah da
kommt er schon okay Leute hier wow Alter
sieht schon verrückt aus
ne
und hier gibt an jedem Gleis jetzt noch
so kleine Shops hier gibt's was zu essen
ich hole einfach mal was ja lass dich
überraschen n gar nich ja ne weiß nicht
mir das mal an Alex ein bisschen
Sushi ich weißw nicht was drin ist aber
ich finde es sieht ganz gut aus alles
klar und komm einfach mal auf gut Glück
hier keine Ahnung was das ist aber wird
schon schmecken
H
okay also der Zug ist schon da wir haben
jetzt was zu essen aber hier sind noch
die Schranken vor das ist auf jeden Fall
wieder so ein Zug da freue ich mich
sogar richtig drauf ja die acht hier
warte mal wir müssen weiter vor weiter
vor was wirklich extrem krass ist guck
mal da ist jetzt einer von den Leuten
die eben hier vorstanden das heißt wenn
der Zug einfährt gehen die alle überall
einmal rein und putzen noch einmal durch
also das ist wirklich schon
krass okay so wir men hier anstellen
glaube ich so wieder in die Schlange l
Mensch ist das hier eine Ordnung ich
komme gar nicht drauf klar so Wagen 8
greenc
AKL Business First Class wie auch
immer
und so wir sind
drin Leute
auf Check
jawoh
jaw m was hast du da Leselampe brauch
wir nur noch ein Buch okay wir fahren
kurzer gefühlscheck wie sich das anfühlt
weil ich war immer auf dem stand dass
der schinkansen auch der schnellste Zug
der Welt ist das ist aber gar nicht so
es gab mal einen Test von dem
schinkansen der ist über 600 kmh
gefahren das ist auch wohl Rekord aber
es gibt weltweit noch schnellere Züge
nur der soll wirklich extrem smooth
fahren und gleiten und ja das werde ich
jetzt kurz
na ja ganz schön aber wir sind noch im
Bahnhof es könnte sogar sein dass das
hier eine Sitzheizung ist wir sind uns
gerade noch nicht sicher Lampe und halt
ja müsste es eigentlich
seinall so wir verlassen tok so langsam
auf jeden Fall riesige stad ja
genau und wenn ich mich jetzt nicht so
wie heute hier aus Filmen konzentrieren
müsste um euch im Ende ein geiles Video
zu liefern vergeht meine Zeit beim
Reisen oft noch schneller Dank bookbeat
jetzt mit dieser fantastischen Aussicht
hier ein geiles Hörbuch das wär es doch
bookbeat ist ein Streamingdienst und
bietet über 800.000 Hörbücher und eBooks
es ist wirklich für jeden mehr als genug
dabei egal für was ihr euch interessiert
ihr werdet sicher nicht enttäuscht ich
höre gerade die Akte Tengelmann das
mysteriöse Verschwinden eines
Milliardärs das Hörbuch ist echt lang
und man wird richtig gefesselt hören ich
zwar lieber als ich lese habe mir aber
mal dieses eBook über meinen
lieblingsfußballferein Borussia Dortmund
vorgenommen auch sehr cool bookbeat
verfügt über jede Menge smarte
Funktionen du kannst deine Interessen
hinterlegen um nur Content vorgeschlagen
zu bekommen der dich wirklich
interessiert deine Hörbücher
herunterladen und offline genießen gut
für den Flieger mit dem schlaftimer
verpasst du keine spannende Minute und
du kannst Bücher und Sprecher bewerten
und vorher Rezension lesen bookbeat
kostet eigentlich 9,99 € im Monat für
Studenten sogar nur 49 jetzt aufpassen
besonders cool mit meinem Code bookbeat
alexv können Zuschauer von mir die App
kostenlos für 60 Tage Gang testen viel
Spaß damit also erster Eindruck so
richtig smooth wie gedacht finde ich es
jetzt nicht fährt eigentlich eigentlich
genauso wie ein ICE auf richtig
Highspeed ne z.B die Strecke Köln
Frankfurt ist ja eh nicht schnell wir
können mal kurz gucken ich versuche
schon die ganze Zeit unseren Speed zu
ermitteln aber irgendwie klappt das
nicht so ganz aber wir sollten auf jeden
Fall 320 fahren hin und wieder mal und
was man mal kurz erwähnen muss warum das
hier alles so optimal funktioniert die
ganzen schinkhansen strerecken sind alle
eingezeäunt also es kann halt nichts von
außen auf die Strecke drauf und die
passagierstrecken sind von Güterzügen
get TR das ist denke ich auch ganz gut
aber ist halt bei uns nicht so ja wir
fahren übrigens immer noch
Null na ja okay Leute und wir fahren
jetzt gerade von toky nach Kyoto in der
Green class aka Business oder First
Class also offiziell heißt es sogar
First Class aber seit 2011 gibt es in
den Norden noch eine Verbindung mit
einer grand class ich zeig euch immer
ein paar Ausschnitte und dort hat man
einen noch bequemeren Sitz und wohl auch
Service direkt zum platzin also das ist
noch mal eine Stufe hier drüber hätte
ich auch machen können nur ich dachte
mir diese Strecke ist interessanter und
wir fahren auch gleich am m vorbei
deswegen da hatten wir irgendwie mehr
Bock drauf und hier haben wir auch ein
bisschen Essen gekauft und das teste ich
jetzt mal Alter ganz schön viele Tunnel
ne fahen Tunnel geh mal davon aus dass
es Eistee oder sowas ähnliches Bar te
mal gucken ob es
schmeckt ach das ist wie dieser
japanische Tee also ohne Zucker ist
eigentlich wie Wasser mit ein bisschen
komischen Nebengeschmack dann haben wir
hier eine Coca-Cola kennst du das habe
ich schon mal getrunken ja echt und hier
haben wir meine japanesische Mystery Box
ich habe keine Ahnung was da drin ist
aber ich denke es wird interessant
Stäbchen aha Alter ich weiß gar nicht
was das gekostet hat ich glaube ungefähr
so etwas über 10 € ich Blend euch hier
mal
ein Mal sticky
rice mm was ist das alles das hier ist
Lachs ne und das das ist eine gnele
jahm
Bohne ja schmeckt bin jetzt nicht so der
Fischfreund und das ist ja schon sehr
fischig aber eine süße Bohne meinst du
Fisch irgendwas
Fisch das mir zu
fischig sieht auf jeden Fall cool aus
mit dem es sieht cool aus unfertig aber
wir sind ja generell noch nicht so warm
geworden mit japanischenem essen wir in
Thailand meinst du das ist alles
durcheinander ne hier hast du ja
wirklich alles glaub eine
hühnerfrikadelle das ist eine Frucht ai
also ich muss sagen ist nicht meins ist
einfach nicht meins so leid es mir tut
es gibt interessante japanische
Süßigkeiten aber dieses Gericht
hier fühle ich jetzt nicht so und das
bekommt man hier im Zug das so
interessant die kommen mal hier durch
und sammeln den Müll ein deswegen also
die Züge hier ist alles blitzeblank
wahscheinlich einfach ein Tuch ne ah ja
wie ein Flugzeug oder halt ne ist für
die Hände damit zurück ins
Studio
[Musik]
also Leute wir fahren jetzt hier gerade
in die Berge rein Kyoto liegt ja auch in
den Bergen ich habe jetzt echt nicht
damit gerechnet dass ich hier so viel
Schnee sehe aber gut macht ja auch Sinn
ne übrigens hier laufen die ganze Zeit
auch Polizisten durch den Zug ich glaube
das ist normal einfach für die
Sicherheit ja kann man ja mal anmerken
Japan hat ja auch viele coole Skigebiete
ich komme jetzt nicht dazu hier Ski zu
fahren aber irgendwann bestimmt mal so
das hier ist
Kyoto sieht aus wie ein Industriepark
ich bin echt mal gespannt auf die Stadt
hier wohnen auch über eine Million
Menschen okay und man steigt jetzt hier
auf der rechten Seite
aus aha und die neuen Gäste kommen von
da rein das heißt man hat kein
Gegenverkehr auch Smart gemacht in Kyoto
hatten wir einen Aufenthalt von 5
Stunden haben uns dann erstmal diese
schöne Tempelanlage hier angeguckt das
war eigentlich ganz entspannt sind dann
Richtung City Center gegangen das ist
irgendwie ziemlich weit weg vom Bahnhof
und man geht durch gasten wo einfach gar
nichts los ist das sieht alles ein
bisschen traurig aus finde ich also
wirklich komplettes Gegenteil zu Toko
dann waren wir noch ein bisschen
einkaufen haben uns noch in ein cffee
Gesetzt ich habe jetzt gar nicht so viel
mitgefilmt weil mir ging es in erster
Linie nur um den Zug erste Eindruck von
Kyoto war nicht so gut ich möchte
mirüber kein Fazit erlauben ich war
einfach zu kurz da okay Leute wir haben
uns jetzt hier noch ein bisschen Kyoto
angeschaut wie ihr sehen könnt es wird
auch langsam schon dunkel ich muss sagen
mein erster Eindruck war echt nicht gut
es sah alles so trist aus und dunkel und
alles irgendwie auch gleich
hallo oh Airport yeah Youtube yes what's
up what's your name Adam Adam California
oh
Germany
kurzesch zum schinkansen auf jeden Fall
ein cooler Zug war ein cooles Erlebnis
ich mir vielleicht auch noch Biss
krasser vorgestellt einfach weil man so
Bo Schink Hansen das war für mich immer
so ich weiß nicht der hat in Deutschland
irgendwie so ein krassen Ruf könnt ihr
vielleicht nachvollziehen ansonsten
hoffe ich das Video hat Euch gefallen
wir fahren jetzt gleich auch schon
zurück nach Tokyo und Leute zurück
geht's übrigens in der Economy wir haben
aber trotzdem super viel Platz hier sind
zwei rein da sind drei und so sieht's
aus wobei die Sitze in der zweiten
Klasse ICE bequemer sind muss man sagen
und so sieht übrigens die Toilette im
schinkhansen aus auf jeden Fall
geräumiger als im ICE aber ja bin ich
ganz okay ute Toilette alex
toilettenprüfsiegel ist drauf war jetzt
hier auch nur viinhal Stunden also ich
kann jetzt auch nicht so viel zu Kyoto
sagen toky gefällt uns auf jeden Fall
besser und vielleicht hätten wir jetzt
hier eine Nacht übernachten müssen um
noch ein größeres Fazit zu ziehen aber
mir ging es in erster Linie um den Zug
abonniert se gerne den Kanal und ja wo
ist jetzt Adam eigentlich ist die Frage
weiß ich nicht wo ist de Rucksack oh
mein
rucko aus
Australien California okay Leute haut
rein
ciao wir haben auf dem Rückweg einfach 2
Minuten Verspätung das gibt's nicht
Frechheit Geld zurück das geht gar nicht